You need to know if
something can be built.
You don't have to know
how to build it yourself,
you just have to know
that it can be done,
and that if you can get
the money from Silicon Valley
or something, you can hire the engineers
to build it for you.
Wesley Boudville, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minutes Leaders.
Welcome to my show.
How are you?
Hello, fine.
I'm calling from Los Angeles
and the weather is cloudy.
Wonderful.
Well, I'm calling from Tel Aviv.
It's been cloudy all week.
But Wes, the reason why
I'm so excited to chat with you
besides, your energy and enthusiasm,
is I get to talk
to an inventor in front of me.
And I love talking to inventors
because I consider myself an inventor
in many capacities.
But the way that you've done it
over the past years
and holding patents
and creating these
innovative technologies
based on a real problems,
I think it's fascinating.
So, Wes, give me
a little bit of background
as to who you are
and why do you consider yourself
an inventor?
Oh, I came to America
in 1983, to Los Angeles,
to get my PhD in theoretical physics.
And from Caltech in LA,
and I did that and then I stayed
in Los Angeles ever since.
And so, I've lived here
much longer than I have
in Australia where I'm from.
And I'm a first generation Australian.
I was born in Malaysia.
I'm Chinese mostly,
and I have a French surname.
It's one of these accidents of history.
But, you know, in Stanford,
you guys are used to that, too.
You get people from everywhere.
100%.
So Wes, how do you stumble upon
this idea of innovation and invention?
What does that even mean to you?
Because I've stumbled,
I think, that's the right way to put it.
I'm trained as a physicist.
I got two degrees of physics, and then
I made my living, after I got my PhD,
as a computer programmer.
Because this was 1989.
And the web was born that year.
And there were plenty of jobs
for programmers.
But in during the dot-com years,
I joined a dot-com startup
and it fell like most of them did.
But then I got hit with a startup bug.
And I've been
in the startup scene ever since.
And in 2008,
I stopped programming.
I programmed computers
from 1979 to 2008, 40 years.
I started in Fortran, I ended at Java.
But then I just, I went to actually
filing patent applications for myself.
And it was by now
I have 20 US patents
under my own name.
I'm single author on 19 of them.
And it's all engineering.
So, I started as a physicist,
but now I'm an engineer,
but I feel like I want to do this
for the rest of my life.
I'm very lucky.
Because for this,
yeah, a lot of people
are not in their jobs.
And I really am,
I feel like I'm in grad school
back at Caltech 30 years ago
because I'm doing research.
And I'm doing it for myself.
Wes, that's one
of the most inspiring things
I've heard in more than 300 episodes.
Tell me a little bit about
these inventions,
these patents that you've created.
What are some of them like?
I have my 20 patents in two groups.
The first group of seven patents,
it's on barcodes like QR codes,
two dimensional barcodes.
And my patents for that
are to control a screen,
electronic screen,
a flat screen that's near you,
a big flat screen that shows an image
and the image shows a barcode.
And so, you take out your cell phone
and you take a photo of the barcode
and you get on your cell phone
a web page.
And that webpage has buttons
you can click, things you can do,
and you can control
the big screen in front of you,
the big flat screen.
And okay, now that's the abstract,
the practical case is
if you are pedestrian on the street
and you're looking at a shop window.
Inside the shop window behind the glass
is a big flat screen showing
something for sale with a barcode.
When you scan the barcode,
you get a search box on your phone,
a webpage.
The search box,
pretend it's Google or something
and you type addresses,
and but when you hit return,
the results are not shown on your phone,
they're shown on the big flat screen
behind the glass.
And so, if it's a dress
or a hat or shirt,
you can see it life size
and you can search
the shop's entire inventory.
That's important because
it solves the problem
that stood for 100 years.
And ever since shop windows
were invented.
The shop window is too small
to show all the goods.
So, every few months
a shop manager has to
refresh the window physically.
She puts in new things.
Well now, she can still do that,
but now you can,
you search whatever you want
and then it'll display in big size.
That makes a lot of sense.
Wes, how do you stumble upon
that invention?
So, I want to take this
and explore this a little bit
more broadly about
what it means to be an inventor.
And so, what I would love
to hear from you
is sort of with these inventions,
how did you even think of them?
Because I'm guessing that
you're not too much
into retail and fashion,
you're not an expert
in retail or fashion,
so, how do you go ahead
and create a patent based on
retail and fashion?
That's right.
That's the hardest.
and it's still the most mysterious thing
for anybody,
unless you are Thomas Edison.
He had a thousand patents.
But the hardest thing is that
at the core of the innovative process.
And the good thing,
one of the thing is that
you need a good and technical education.
You don't have to be an engineer
or a scientist, but it helps.
But you need to know
if something can be built.
You don't have to know
how to build it yourself.
You just have to know
that it can be done
and then if you can get the money
from Silicon Valley or something,
you get to hire the engineers
to build it for you.
So, I guess for me
with a barcode thing,
I imagined it
and I got the patents on it.
But I just,
like a remote control of a screen
that's what I was thinking of
without being able to touch it.
What I'm doing right now,
my main focus on my most,
of my 13 other patents
are an alternative to domains
or domain name system.
And domains were used in the 1970s
because when the Internet was born,
there were no domains.
So, you would then
email or log in to like john@
and then you give an internet address
like UCLA.
But nobody wanted to remember that
so, domains themselves were invented
so that people could write john@UCLA.edu
or john@stanford.edu
I did not know
that's why domains were invented,
by the way.
Domains actually are older than the web.
The web is 1989
of the world wide web, html, 1989.
And before that, people had,
you know, people had email addresses
at Stanford, UCLA, Caltech
and also in HP.
So, but yeah.
Because the first killer app
of the internet was probably email.
And email needed domain.
Email help create domains.
And then the second killer app
was really up the web later on.
For sure.
So, then talk to me
a little bit about this,
about more broadly this domain problem.
And why do you need 13 patents
to address that?
Domains or DNS,
which is domain name system,
it was invented so that
you did not have to memorize
an Internet address,
which were then like
10.15.25.128.
Something that is meaningless,
even for engineers.
And back then,
when domain's were invented,
the older users of the web,
let's say an e-mail
were the hard core researchers.
There's nobody.
There were engineers and professors
and grad students throughout the US.
So, they were serious people.
But even they could see
the immediate use
of a domain name system.
MIT.ed was simple to remember.
And the things like this.
And so, in what I'm doing right now
with this thing called Linket,
which are an alternative to domains
I faced a similar problem
of people having to memorize
too long alphanumeric strings
that didn't really mean anything.
But then I realized,
and so, I remember that day
I was walking to a park in Pasadena
and I was just thinking
about this problem
and I realized that we were we,
the human race were here before
in the 1970s and 80s,
that then they had a problem
of trying to remember internet addresses.
So, you avoid that problem,
DNS is the solution to that.
Here they have something
called deep links
which were used,
which were actually invented
in Silicon Valley in the early 2010s.
And I put it,
but the deep links
that these too long of strings,
one string is just like
an app ID in an app store.
But nobody really wants to remember
an app ID even if you could.
Of course.
Yeah.
And so, I just came up with the idea
of just putting a label on it
and I just had called
the label something.
I couldn't call it domain
because that's not quite what it is,
so, I just thought Linket.
Because it's like link,
like LinkedIn and all that link,
it's a connection.
And also, the big thing for mine
was that right now
they use something called Unicode,
which, you know about it
if you could be the programmer.
Unicode is a way to represent
every written human language.
Domains are really A to Z
because when they were invented late 70s,
that's all we had.
Unicode did not exist.
And so, the American engineers
who invented DNS,
they were not trying
to act against other countries,
to discriminate against other countries.
Let me just say that,
because it turns out
domains, you can't even
for European languages
written in Roman alphabet
of all the other
European languages have accents.
So, the Spanish have tilde over the end.
But you can't do a tilde domain,
you can't do French, German,
Italian, none of them.
Let alone the other languages,
would use different alphabets like, well,
like Cyrillic, Greek, Hebrew,
Arabic and all that, you just can't.
So, right now,
with my stuff with Linket.
I start with Unicode.
Which means I can do
all the languages from scratch right now.
Wow.
So, how do you actually see this unfold?
You mentioned that
you've written a series of patents
to go about this,
even before we continue with Linket,
talk to me about the process
of writing a patent.
You sit down and you have this idea,
how does it actually work
end to end?
Yeah. Oh, okay.
Actually, I taught classes of this,
like patent to new invention.
Yeah, exactly.
It turns out if you're an engineer
and if you have an
undergraduate degree in engineering
or science,
you can basically write a patent.
You have enough technical training
to do that.
Because it's just like you writing,
like if you are a senior in engineering,
you're writing a term paper
in your senior year
on some of you work in a lab.
And like when you're told
to pretend that just submitting it
to an academic journal,
and may maybe you are,
maybe your professor is.
It's the same sort of thing
that you have to use formal language,
but you don't need
to use any legal language,
despite what a patent attorney
might say to you.
And here's the thing,
like in San Francisco,
when you use a patent attorney,
everything's more expensive
there in San Francisco,
you know, well you already
did know that,
but it could cost easily $5,000
to file a patent application.
That's just to pay the attorney.
And it's about $500
to pay the government.
And then you wait,
oh, but if you are into startups,
you guys, one of the things to do
the good thing to do
is that if you have an idea
about a patent application,
if you have to pay the attorney
or you do it yourself whatever,
you file the patent application,
let's say, next week,
but the government gets it,
but nothing will happen
for the next 18 months.
So then, you would go
with your receipt.
You get a serial number
of the patent application.
Sure.
And then use that to show like investors,
angels and VCs,
and you can build it out
if you can afford it.
Like if it's a mechanical thing,
it's a software ,
because you have 18 months
where nothing will happen
with your patent application.
So, that's the way to do it.
You should not file, like just
you shouldn't build it first and file
because you lose the time.
And time is everything.
So, what happens if you file a patent
and then within those 18 months
you have other people that are filing
those provisional patents
on a similar idea.
Well that's just it, okay,
that 18 months,
you just don't know.
You really don't know.
Because the provisionals,
they are published
or even the patents pending,
which is what I do.
I do not file provisionals.
I filed the full patents pending
a patent pending.
That's a bit more expensive.
But anyway, for the 18 months
your application will be published.
So, nobody else could see it
for 18 months.
But it also means you can't see.
So, you don't know
that the next 18 months,
if somebody else was actually
did it early before you.
So, it's a little bit nerve racking,
especially if you have a valuable idea.
Now the following year
is just like empirical.
But put it this way,
in that 18 months,
every week, like, for example,
when you look at
the new patent application
they published every week,
if you don't see somebody else
coming up with your idea,
then every week the odds improve
that your idea was the first.
It's not a proof,
but it's just like playing the odds.
Of course.
Especially,
and it increases the odds
that Google and Microsoft
and other big companies have new idea.
Because once they
have filed a patent application,
they don't have to wait, they or you,
once you get a receipt back
from the government,
you can talk about it
the next day.
Right.
And so when you look
at Google or Microsoft,
if they have filed a patent application,
like of the same idea as yours,
like yesterday,
then today they could just publicize,
they could publish them with themselves,
on their blog, whatever,
they were allowed to do that legally.
But they have all the money in the world
to do that, to scare people away.
If they don't do that,
they probably haven't done that.
Yeah. I love the rationale.
So, Wes, tell me a little bit
about Linket.
You've written your last few patents
based on this, on the domain space.
From my understanding,
what you're trying to do
is you're trying to democratize these domains
so that really we can use Unicode,
which really has any character
that we have on our computer
to create those domains.
Why are you doing that
and what are the possible implications
of doing this link?
The big first problem is that
for the last 20 years,
the top dot-com domains
that are English words
have been bought by people who speculate.
And there's nothing wrong with that.
But I'm just saying this is
what they've done.
And today the speculators
are called Domainers.
Some of them
do this full time for living.
What does that mean?
What do they do?
Oh, they bought like a domain,
like these are the dot-com domains.
Because the most valuable domains
right now are still
in the dot-com of space.
And so, it will be like reason.com,
ramen.com or curry.com,
things with commercial value.
By the way,
is dot-com valuable mainly
because that's what people are used to?
Yes.
That's the only reason right?
Right.
And so, but there's no
intrinsic reason for this, okay?
But as a result of that,
there were now
a thousand top level domains.
In the year 2000,
there was about 200 of TLDs,
the 200 TLDs then were basically
like the dot-com,
like the five or six original of TLDs,
plus the TLDs that were country codes,
the two-letter country codes,
.UK, .AU you know, all those.
And then they added 800 more
in the last 20 years,
mostly in the last 10 years.
Those are doing okay,
but nobody's really
making much money on it
from what I understand.
So, yes, anybody can still get a domain
if you don't really care
what the suffixes,
what the TLD you are in.
But by reasons of prestige,
it's like the dot-com years
were responsible for this.
Even the name dot-com.
The dot com bubble, right.
100%.
Yeah.
So, what are you trying to do now
with removing that ending?
What it means is that today,
if you are startup in Silicon Valley,
for example, and you want to get like a,
you want the foodservice something
and you want to get like ramen.com,
because maybe you sell
like Indian food or something.
Just like, for that you'd
like to get ramen.com.
But let's say you go there,
you look at somebody else owns it
and they want $20,000 for it.
Now, maybe they want less,
sometimes they can want more.
They can ask whatever amount they want.
Now, they'll give an actual number.
Business.com in 1993,
somebody bought that directly
from VeriSign for the first time.
And they paid like, back then,
the standard price was like,
$300 a year, something like that.
In 1999, at the height of the dot-com,
it was sold for about five million dollars.
Five million at that time.
And yeah, it's something like that.
It's in the records.
And the price that the buyer bought it
for five million dollars the buyer paid
was probably still a good deal
because since '99,
the web has grown and grown.
And, you know, we added over
a billion people, and yeah,
in India, China, Europe,
as well as America.
So, yeah, you can imagine.
So, that's right.
And so, right now,
what we're doing is that
we are selling these Linkets,
well, $15, that's one, five.
And so, that's
two or three orders cheaper
than you can buy the dot-com,
the equivalent dot-com domain
from a domainer.
And so, how do they look?
So, instead of like okay,
I use the example ramen.com.
I don't really know
how much it's going for,
but that's just like somebody else
wanting like $20,000.
That's about reasonable.
The equivalent Linket,
it's just ramen.
with ramen in square brackets.
That's it. Ramen in square brackets.
Yeah. We sell them for $15. One, five.
So, it's three orders in magnitude
less than $20,000.
By the way, I have a question.
Because this is all about
supply and demand.
Right?
I mean it's basic economics.
You know, the reason why
ramen.com is high in prices
is because you have a lot
of potential buyers.
So, you increase the price.
But now let's say that somebody buys
from you for $15
the square brackets ramen,
and now there's going to be a demand
as people transition to Linket instead
of the dot-com,
you're going to be the mainstream.
So, it's going to be, again,
a seller's market, right?
Well, yeah.
Well, I think we're selling
too low right now,
but we are just starting.
And so, we have to,
price is one of our
main advantages right now.
And later on we will sell.
Oh, but we also have a reserve list.
Because this is what the domain
registrars are doing today already.
Some of the domains right now,
they'll sell at high prices.
We have a reserve list of words like.
So, basically right now
it's English words.
And words like Intel,
which doesn't mean Intel Corporation,
the chip maker.
It's just intel means intelligence,
like military intelligence.
So, we'll select the linket,
just intel of the linket,
or computer,
that's all of these we reserve.
And we want to,
we'll start selling these off like
two or three years down the road.
We'll auction it off.
So, we're going to let the market decide.
And our reserved list right now,
it's about 20,000 reserved Linkets.
We're going to grow that to 100,000.
Because we said we do Unicode.
We are going to use, like the word intel,
we will reserve that
in French and Italian
and German and in Chinese,
all of these.
So, essentially right now with domains,
with the domainers,
everybody's working in English basically.
Right.
Now, with Linkets,
it's dictionaries in every language.
So, we just do it over again.
And that's how we want
to make our money one day.
I think that's just spectacular.
And so, Linket,
I'm guessing it's a company
that is now running.
And is it actually active?
Does it work that I can actually use
for a bracket to go to websites?
Well, yeah.
I mean, people can go,
they can apply it.
And If nobody has it then we'll send,
then they can buy it from us.
If it's not on our reserve list,
we'll sell it to them.
And then we have instructions
which are this is our alpha version.
We have instructions
on how they can,
if they were a coder,
if they were a computer programmer,
how do they get like mod
their web pages to use the Linkets.
It's early days right now.
There's a long way to go.
But right now,
I'd like to think
that right now it's like
in 1992 when you could buy business.com
for the first time.
Even if you didn't know
how to write a webpage,
even if you did know HTML,
just only because when you buy
the domain today, even today,
you still don't have do anything with it.
You don't [--] website,
you could just own it.
I remember, we have an interesting story
when my uncle bought shoes.com
many years ago and it obviously
became very valuable actually.
And it actually
it prompted him and his partners
to start a company called shoes.com
which later sold.
But, I did definitely understand
the value of domain.
But Wes, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
I love this conversation.
So much energy.
And I just love going all the way
back to the beginning.
You saying how lucky you are
to be in a place where
you feel like you're back
in grad school in Caltech
and doing these
extraordinary research things.
And I just love your passion, enthusiasm.
So, thank you for sharing that.
Before we leave, the hardest question.
I need three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Intelligent, inventor, engineer.
I love that.
Wes, thank you very much.
Best of luck with Linket.
I'm going to go buy
my own Linket right now.
Thank you very much for everything.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Yeah. You're welcome.
Thank you.